[Music]
hello rob this is uh tim from chicago
really enjoy the podcast i have a
question about one of your movies i
think it's the best romantic comedy ever
made
filmed in uh i think 86 that came out it
was called about last night
it was a
great
movie about chicago where i'm from so
really enjoyed that movie my question is
do you think
if
do dan and debbie stay together did they
get married or did they live happily
ever after are they gonna
you know at the end they kind of left it
open there but
do you think they'd still be together
in your opinion
all right thank you so
much oh
thank you so much
greatest romantic comedy of all time
i'll take it um i do like that movie a
lot by the way and i i put it up there i
definitely with all humility
put it up there with any romantic comedy
i really do
um of course we're both biased you live
in chicago and i'm in it so what the
hell do you and i know but
that said um it's funny we there were
two sequel scripts written
for that movie um addressing that very
question they were really good both of
them and they just never got made for
whatever reason
i definitely think danny and debbie got
together and and lived happily ever
after i mean
100 and and there was a
there was a moment in time where i would
have loved to maybe i would still do it
where you would
you would go back and not even go back
but revisit what whatever happened to
them um but that's a function of how
brilliant that script was
based on a david mamet play
sexual perversity in chicago was the
name of it and then tim kazarinsky and
denise de clue
saturday night live another they wrote
the
screenplay
and um yeah it's one for sure of the of
the 80s era movies i did definitely the
one i'm most proud of so i'm glad that
you you like it too appreciate your call
thanks so much
you